okay so we start Rome today and we will
spend the next four classes on the rise
of the Roman Republic and then the rise
of the Roman um Empire so um Rome
traditionally We Believe Rome was
founded in the year 753 BC but we don't
know okay that's just what tradition
says that's what what the Romans believe
we actually don't know okay so um around
this time Rome it's just like a small
insignificant Kingdom in the middle of
Italy okay it's it was started on the
Tyber this is Rome and it's part of
Italy um called a Latin area Okay so
this these people are known as the
Latins now at this time um and over the
next centuries Rome would be a small
poor uh Kingdom or was at war with its
neighbors okay primarily the sabins over
here and then you have other tribes as
well at this time the dominant
civilization is what we call the
atrians and the atrans are the most
advanced civilization in Italy um during
this time and it is very similar to
Greece in that there are different city
states um and they trade with each other
other and because they are by the Sea
they are able to
access um cultures and ideas and goods
from all around the world okay um then
across the Mediterranean you have a
place called
Carthage um here is Italy uh Sicily okay
and I call Sicily SI Sicily is important
because it's basically the main island
of the Mediterranean so if you want to
control the the Mediterranean Sea and
the trade you have to control Sicily all
right um so across the sea is Carthage
and Carthage is um from it's a colony of
Phoenicia which is in the lavant okay
and over the next few hundred years
Carthage would become the dominant
economic power of the Mediterranean
because they're very good at trade and
they're very good at um sailing okay so
they'll they'll they'll travel and sail
all around the world and found new
colonies and slowly they'll build up um
their own little Empire across the
Mediterranean and they are for the
longest time the wealthiest
city um in Europe basically okay and um
of course over here are the Greeks right
and we spend a lot of time discussing
the Greeks so around this time about 500
BC if you would look at these three
major civilizations right or sorry
there's actually four right the the
tristans the Greeks uh the carthaginians
and then the then you have these
Romans
um no one could expect or predict that
the Romans would become the great Empire
that it did become
right so what we will look at the first
class is how did Rome become so powerful
and the answer the easy answer is it's
good at War it's really good at War and
then the question then is well why is it
good at War why is it better than the
Greeks or the carthaginians and the
answer is uh because it's not because
the Romans are not afraid to die and
because the Romans have a different
conception of sinship than the Greeks
okay remember the Greeks were extremely
jealous of
CIP uh it was very hard to become an
Athenian it was very hard to become a
Spartan you basically you basically have
to be born into the Polish uh same thing
with the carthaginians they were much
they were not as um strict as the Greeks
they were pretty inflexible as well
they're very proud of being of being a
citizen Rome because it was the poorest
and
smallest it it had no choice if you
wanted to immigrate to Rome they welcome
you as a citizen and as such they could
throughout his history draw on the
vast uh Manpower pool in the surrounding
areas okay and as such um with their
almost
unlimited uh Manpower resources they
could eventually overwhelm the Greeks
and the carthaginians become the
dominant power in the Mediterranean by
about 200 BC okay that's the easy answer
and that's what most historians and most
scholars
believe but I want to be I I want to be
more precise okay I want to show you
that ultimately it's the value
system or what is known as the character
of these different civilizations that
ultimately that ultimately determine
their fate and future okay does that
make sense all right so um
so about 500 BC Rome becomes a republic
and at this time the rusian culture is
dominating Rome in fact um for three out
of Rome seven Kings previously were a
Tristian okay so culturally and
traditionally speaking the Christians
have this huge impact on Rome but
because Rome is very good at War it's
slowly able to expand and conquer ER the
trishkin and basically control all of
Italy okay and because the Romans are
expansionist by Nature they are they are
a warlike people they are basically a
war machine they all they now want to
control
um
Sicily and the coast okay and this
brings them into conflict with the
Greeks because remember the Greeks when
they built colonies they buil it either
on Islands or near the coast because
that's what allows them to trade and
also connect with the Greek diaspora
around the Mediterranean and the aan
okay and in about
280 the Greeks in southern uh Italy they
call for help and remember at this time
the Greek world is dominant throughout
the
world okay so Alexander conquered most
of the world and his generals now
control most of the ter to and one of
the successors to Alexander his name is
pyrus okay he decides this is
opportunity for him to build his own
Empire So he responds
to uh the Greeks who call for help
against Rome okay so Rome is threatening
the Greeks in southern Italy the Greeks
are asking for help from the compatriots
pyrus um comes with an army to help his
comp Patriots and remember at this time
the Greeks had the best military in the
world because of the hobik
phallic and pyus is destroying the
Romans battle after battle pyus is
destroying and decimating the
Romans eventually pyus says this wow um
I'm winning so many wars I'm winning so
many battles and if I continue to win
battles I will be completely out of
men I will have no more soldiers left
okay and this this is what the F this is
where the phrase
peric Victory comes from right you can
win but the costs of Victory are so high
you might as well have lost all right
and so what this means is even though
the Romans were militarily inferior to
the Greeks the Romans weren't afraid to
die and they inflicted so many
casualties on
the Greeks that the Greeks eventually
had to withdraw okay and this will start
many centuries of war between the Romans
and the Greeks remember at this time in
the beginning the Greeks are wealthier
more
numerous and more military dominant than
the Romans but eventually because of the
Roman way of War Rome will eventually
conquer the Greeks okay so that's the
Greeks um
eventually the Romans went Sicily and
this brings them brings them into direct
conflict with Carthage and they starts
what is called the first Punic War now
there's a problem
Carthage is a naval power Rome is a land
power Rome has no
Navy so what Rome does is slowly over
time it builds its own Navy and at first
sucks they lose a lot of ships and so
the Romans build more ships and they get
slaughtered by the caragan at Sea so
they build more ships and more ships and
more ships eventually they overwhelm the
carthaginians and so after 20 years of
war in what is called the first Punic
War um Rome becomes a dominant Naval
power in the Mediterranean carage
becomes second
then something strange happens okay um
Carthage it is a trading power is a
maritime
power and but and while it's able to
dominate its neighbors okay it establish
Empire in Northern Africa and in
Spain it it it loses a lot of Wars
against the Greeks and the Romans who
are just better Warriors okay but then
the carians produce a man named hanb
Hannibal
harba Hannibal Barka and Hannibal Bara
is considered by many military
historians to be the greatest General
who ever
lived as a military strategist Hannibal
had
no um competitor
okay and Hannibal Barka he hates Rome
with a passion he understands this he
understands that Rome
is fundamentally an expansionist
military power Rome will not stop until
it has conquered the
world so even though technically
Carthage and Rome are at
peace eventually Rome Will Comfort
Carthage so this better to take the
fight to Rome first than to wait for
Rome to come to you okay
now um Carthage at this time it is
basically a republic like Rome and it's
run by people call by something called
Council of
Elders okay these are the wealthiest
citizens in um Carthage and there's
elements of democracy and arlock is as
well but it's primarily Republic okay
it's run by these people and these are
merchants these are wealthy people war
is bad for business okay so they were
not supportive of Hannibal in his desire
for war against
Rome so Hannibal did two Hannibal did
two things okay the first thing
is um he was in charge of civil mines in
Spain and what he did was he conquered a
lot more a lot of Spanish territory for
Carthage and and and so he was able to
amass more wealth he took this wealth
and he used it to basically bribe the
coun of Elders to leave him alone okay
and to support his military adventures
in Spain and again these are business
people if it's profitable they will
support
you and then what hanal did was he did
something that thought that was
unimaginable before he took his army and
he crossed cross the Alps okay he
crossed the Alps sorry the Alps are
here into Italy he is now at Rome's
doorstep and again before Hol did this
it was fought un it was found impossible
to cross the Alps especially in winter
with an army okay but hell did that he
lost a lot of men and elephants war
elephants in his Crossing but he was
able to to cross and when he crossed he
was able to summon all lot of allies to
his side okay because Rome was at war
with everyone in Italy and with the guls
to the north of Italy and France okay so
so Rome had a lot of enemies and so
Hannibal was able to replenish his
forces once he landed in Italy it was
also very charismatic uh speaker a great
General
okay um Rome heard about this and at
first r were shocked but they weren't
scared War Rome is a war machine okay so
they decided to send an Army against
Hannibal and army after Army fell
against Hannibal Hannibal was able to
defeat Roman uh soldiers and armies
using
Superior military tactics and strategies
okay then the Romans decide you know
what here's what we're going to do we'll
take two years off and we're going to
build the world world's largest army
okay 880,000
men and at this time Hannibal had about
40,000
men and then we'll take these 880,000
soldiers and we'll just throw at
Hannibal and Crush Hannibal and the war
will be over okay and that's the
strategy that's just the Roman way okay
the Romans are not creative they are
just uh brutal bold and direct okay
that's just that that's just their way
of War
and
so at and so henbo meets his 880,000
um Soldier Army at something called at a
place called canine and they fight
something called The Battle of canine in
216 BC and this is the most famous
battle in human
history okay remember the Romans
outnumber Hannibal 2
to1 and what hanal does is he decides
Ides on a place to face the Romans okay
and in this place it's a small
Valley and so even though the Romans are
numerically Superior because it's the
value is small they're forced to march
in a straight line as opposed in a wide
line okay you have if you have more
numbers you want to march in a wide line
but because of the geography they're
forced to march in a uh straight long
line okay so they're marching this way
Hannibal is uphill with his
army and he does something strange he
organizes his army not in a straight
line but in a concave line okay like
this
concave and the Romans look at this and
they laugh because they've never seen
anything like this before and they think
it's a it's a sign of weakness it means
the military under
handable it's
undisciplined they're just amateurs this
will be over in an hour okay so the
Romans are Marching confidently in
against Hannibal they're
attacking on the wings of both armies
are the horsemen the calvalry okay so
what happens as the Romans March against
Hannibal is Hannibal sends his Cavalry
against the Roman calvalry and they
overwhelm the Roman Cavalry okay and now
they're turning back in
to attack the flank or the back
meanwhile the Roman attack it's so
powerful the surch is so strong that
the
concave of Han's Army Turns Upside
Down okay it turns upside
down when it does
so it traps the Roman army in a circle
okay do do you see this okay now they
are inside a circle and the Army is
coming around and attack him from the
back okay militarily we call this the
double envelopment strategy okay double
envelopment
strategy and so the Romans are are
Circle completely and what follows is
the greatest
massacre in history militarily until War
one the army of 880,000
that uh the Romans sent lost almost
70,000 men 70,000 men died that day and
again no military lose so much men until
World War I when they had much larger
armies like millions of people and when
they had like machine guns all right so
this is like the greatest military
disaster in human history up to this
point the disaster is so
great that right now Rome has lost 20%
okay
20% of its adult male
population to put that in context in
World War I the Germans lost anywhere
between 10 to 15% of their adult male
population before they were forced to
surrender to the Allies okay so Rome has
lost 20% it's lost a third of the Senate
the Senate is the highest governing body
of Rome so a third of their leadership
is
dead at the same
time Hannibal is able to convince the
Greeks to start a second front against
the
Romans
okay so at this point the war is
basically
over and Han sends envoys to Rome and
says listen um the war is over I'm
willing to
negotiate a peace
settlement I am willing to negotiate
peace
terms and there something strange
happens and this is unique in human
history okay the Roman senate they come
together and they discuss a situation
it's Bleak it's hopeless
but they're
Romans Romans do not
surrender so the Senate told Hannibal we
will continue the war we will raise
another Army if you want to um come
attack us come we we will be ready for
you and this is completely unexpected
okay hbal does not know what to
do and this war continues and this again
is
um this war continues for
another 15 years and then 15 years later
the Romans have won they
destroyed the carthaginian presence in
Spain and they've conquered and they've
Len it in in Africa and forced carford
to surrender all
right okay so this is a mystery
why did the Romans not surrender and how
were the Romans able to defeat not just
the carthaginians but also the Greeks
and also like everyone else okay because
at that time Hannibal basically unit the
entire world against Rome against Rome
and Rome in the end even though it was
very costly right they did win so that's
a
mystery okay
so um
first thing we need to understand is
traditional military Doctrine about who
wins Wars it's basically wrong
traditionally we understand the military
about three things okay Manpower how
many soldiers do you have technology how
good are your weapons and resources how
wealthy are you okay traditionally we've
understood War
making um
like if you're good at War you will have
these three things okay lots of soldiers
lots of technology and lots of
money and if you an it an analyze it
this way then
Rome should be no match against carage
right Carthage is a lot
wealthier uh it has more technology it
has the greatest General in
Hannibal but then at the same time the
the Athenians should not have been able
to defeat the the Persians at the same
time Alexander and the macedonians
should not have been able to defeat the
Persians in fact throughout human
history we've have a lot of instances
cases where smaller armies have been
able to defeat much larger armies so
think of gang Khan think of Muhammad
okay so clearly this is wrong but if
this is wrong what is a better way to
understand military
strength well I would argue how strong
military uh is is based on three
criteria the first is
cohesion do the soldiers
like and identify with each other are
they United Okay cohesion second is the
idea of
discipline how well trained and
experienced are they and the third is
devotion
how committed are they to
winning okay so if you want to see how
powerful a nation is militarily you have
to ask yourself these three questions
are they cohesive are they disciplined
are they
devoted okay and I would also argue that
each nation has a certain culture a
certain value
system which makes which gives it a
certain character and this character
will tell you you if they are likely to
win a war or not okay all right so let's
examine briefly the charact
characteristics of Rome as opposed to
the Greeks and the carthaginians okay so
let's let's do a table let's just say
okay you have Ro you have
Greeks you have Carthage you have
Rome all right we know a lot about the
Greeks and there are three major
Concepts that Define Greek culture okay
all right so the first question is what
makes you a good person for the Greeks
it was the idea of
er er just means Excellence you could be
an you could be a jerk but you
have ER like you have talent then you're
a good person okay and the ER that the
Greeks um are most concerned about um is
the ability to speak well and the
ability to fight well okay that's
irritate second
is what is the thing that matters to you
okay the most valuable thing in your
life well why do you fight well for the
Greeks it was the idea
Freedom okay and for them the idea
Freedom means the ability to speak your
mind in front of your peers okay the
freedom of speech
basically and the last question for the
Greeks is what is the purpose of life
okay and here the Greeks have an easy
answer it's
udonia remember udonia is Greek for
flourishing you can only be happy as a
person if you are achieving your true
potential if you are flourishing as a
person okay
so that's Greek culture and you you
think about it this explains why the
Greeks the most creative civilization in
human history right they're very
creative at the same time they're also
very selfish right and that's why they
were never able to come together except
in times of National Emergency like when
the Persians invaded and only then but
but even then only a few of the Greek
city states came together and some even
joined the Persians okay so the Greeks
are notorious for being creative but
also being for being selfish so that's
Greek culture now let's look at the
cagans okay now unfortunately we don't
know anything about the carthaginians
the reason why is Rome wiped Carthage
out of History okay Rome destroyed
Carthage killed everyone and erased
Carthage from the history
books but we do know they are a mertile
Empire meaning they are focused on trade
we also know that in their political
system it's the wealthiest citizen who
have the most political power okay and
so they are basically a merchant culture
a merchant mertile culture and from that
we can we can make certain guesses about
their value system okay so what is good
for the cians it's the idea of being
lucky right you succeed in life if
you're lucky that's how business people
right are that's why they're very
superstitious the cians are notorious
for being extremely religious and
superstitious
and one example of this is of all these
major civilizations the cagans are known
for practicing human sacrifice in fact
in times of War they will even go as far
as practicing child sacrifice killing
children uh killing children and
sacrificing them them to the gods and
return for divine favor in times of War
okay so they are known for focusing on
Fortune and luck
um what do they care about they care
about their own interests right what's
profitable what's their purpose in life
accumulating
wealth right does that make sense
because these are business people
they're
Merchants so that's how they
structure uh their society and their
culture and that's why for most of their
history they were extremely wealthy okay
they were notorious for being extremely
clever
um business
people who made a lot of money for
themselves okay
Rome uh let's look at Rome
okay what is good for them what's a good
person the answer is piety Pages means
uh duty to the gods to the City Rome and
to your father okay they believe they
believe heavily in filial piety the best
person was someone who practiced F
piety
okay what did they think was most
valuable in their lives is thata of
Liberty okay but Liberty is a different
conception for the Romans than for the
Greeks remember for the Greeks What
mattered was the
opportunity and the ability to speak
your mind in front of your peers okay
that what's that's what Freedom
was the Romans believed
Liberty was about respect
respecting the
law the institutions and the history of
Rome but it is only by restructing a law
could you be
free otherwise we' all just be Savages
okay that's the conception of
Liberty now the last question then is
what's the purpose of life and for the
Romans what really mattered to them is
the idea of Rua
this is Latin and it's translated as
usually public virtue for the public
good okay and this is where we get the
term republic from and so for Romans the
highest
honor the highest privilege the purpose
of life was to serve Rome and make it
stronger and
better okay does that make
sense setting for political office
and being head of the military was the
highest honor Rome could bestow on you
that was the entire point of Point um of
your life okay does that make sense okay
so if you if we just do a comp a
compared contrast we could easily figure
out oh it's the Roman ethical system
that will allow them the most cohesion
discipline and devotion in their
military and therefore over time
in a war the Romans should be able to
defeat both the carthaginians and the
Greeks okay does that matter sorry does
that make sense to
you okay any questions so
far is this clear my my
argument
carians
yeah okay
all right so Rome in the third pinic war
from 149 to 146 they would go and
Destroy Carthage they would burn it to
the ground and then they they would burn
all the books that um Carthage ever
produced so we don't have anything
written by them but we have a lot
written by Greeks and Romans right
because the Greeks and Romans Were
Always In conflict with uh the
carthaginians and what's interesting for
us is before all the collect started in
about 300 BC the Romans and the Greeks
had nice things to say about the
carthaginians okay they were good
Fighters they were Brave they were very
prosperous carage was like uh the
wealthiest city in the world okay they
were they had all these Praises for
carage and after when War started
between uh the cagans and the Romans
then they focus on like child sacrifice
the carthaginians were offended the G
Gods because they practice child
sacrifice which is barbaric and that's
why the gods smited Carthage okay
remember back at this time in human
history we didn't believe in human
agency everything was was ordained by
the gods okay so if car is destroyed
it's because of God's will it why do the
God's will it because the cagans
practiced child
sacrifice okay and that's what the
Romans and the Greeks insisted of course
that means we have to be skeptical IAL
of what they say right but at the same
time we've done a lot of archaological
excavations around carage and we have
found uh human human remains that show
signs of human sacrifice okay so uh we
have the we have uh we also Carthage
comes from Phoenicia right we know a lot
about photian culture Okay so we've lost
a lot of information about Carthage but
we're able to piece them back together
um slowly does that make sense all
right okay but again uh unfortunately we
know nothing about their culture right
we don't know nothing about their
literature about their mythology about
their religion because it's all been
destroyed the writing has all been
destroyed by the Romans
okay so these three characteristics that
define the Roman identity right um piety
Liberty
and R Papa I I want to explain them
slowly okay so what the Romans really
did
well is they they basically created
history as
mythology okay so the Greeks separated
mythology from history mythology is what
the Greeks did history is what humans
did okay so basically the Greeks
invented uh um history the Romans they
basically Elevate their history into
mythology they're their history became
their religion okay so so let me explain
what I mean by that
so there are legends that surround the
founding of Rome so Rome was supposed to
be founded in 7 753 BCE by ramulus okay
and there there are legends surrounding
Romulus and there are lots of Legends
surrounding romules but the idea is this
there was a
king and he was overthrown by his
brother and the brother banished the
King's Daughter to a temple to be a
virgin for the rest of her life but then
she got pregnant and then so the brother
says to uh the King's Daughter why are
you pregnant and the daughter says I was
visited by
Mars the god of war and he
impregnant
me okay the king's brother obviously
does not believe her so she ban he
banishes her and he orders uh for the
twins who are born to be killed okay but
um as the case with these
Legends uh the person charged with
killing the twins takes pity on them and
somehow they are are left to die in the
woods a She Wolf a wolf comes and nurses
them before another Shepherd comes and
adopts them okay eventually they realize
who they are and they help the
king overthrow the brother and take back
the take back the
throne now the brothers are asked to go
and basically uh found their own City so
they go to Rome and it's all just Hills
right and they decide this is the place
to build their Kingdom because a river
the Tiber and there are all these Hills
that provide good uh
defense okay the problem is this they're
twins there's two of them Romus and
Remis so and only one can be king so
they're so they get get into a battle
and Romus kills
Remis okay and that's the founding
Legend
of Rome and from this Legend we we can
sort of understand
or make some extrapolations about the
Roman
psychology they believe that violence is
at the core of human existence
right I mean the
like sometimes you have to kill your own
brother and that's the right thing to do
because that is ordained by the gods
okay so that's the first uh Legend
second Legend is this Romas has to build
Rome and he becomes a very open person
he welcomes immigrants into Rome and he
grants some
citizenship and Status right away okay
Rome becomes a nation of
immigrants eventually their rise
startles their neighbors and their
neighbors go to war with them at once
but the Romans are so good at war that
they fight back the neighbors uh the
neighbors are called the
saines the saines decide listen we can't
put them in war but at the same time
Rome is only has MA males right Rome
only has males so
we will just isolate Rome our daughters
will not marry into Rome and in and in
20 years time Rome will have no
population okay ROM hears of this plan
and he devises a strategy what he does
is he organizes a huge Festival invites
all his neighbors so fathers bring their
daughters to attend this festival at
this
Festival um the women are
kidnapped and they're basically raped
that night raminus visits every one of
uh these women and apologizes for what
has for what has happened and promised
that they will be safe in Rome that they
are now citizens of Rome and therefore
they will be protected by him personally
the
king the fathers and the brothers are
obviously very upset about this so they
organized this huge Army and they March
against Rome the Roman uh citizens come
out to face them in battle okay and just
just as they're about to clash in battle
the woman come and run between them and
beg the new husbands and their fathers
and brothers not to fight at this point
Romus appears and
says he will make everyone a citizen of
Rome okay and by doing that he basically
double the population of
Rome all right again from this Legend we
we can understand the Roman psychology
which is
everything can be
sacrificed in the pursuit of Roman
glory and basically uh to ensure that
Roman that Rome survives okay because
what matters is Rome okay it's a cult of
Rome all that matters is survival of
Rome morals don't
matter nothing matters all that matters
is survival
role so after this Rome starts to grow
slowly and this is a period known as as
the seven Kings so there's seven Kings
who rule Rome and they do so for a very
long time about 200 plus years and most
of them are very very good Kings except
the last king his name is taranis
taranas Superbus okay Superbus is Latin
for arrogant so he's often referred to
as
Tarkin the proud okay
okay so T proud he is as his name
suggests a very arrogant King what makes
him what makes him arrogant is his
hubris he refuses to listen to the
nobility in fact those in in the
nobility who challenge his authority
often get
killed
right um he he has a second son and the
second son he's a jerk he likes to abuse
his power the one thing that he like he
enjoys doing is raping the woman of Rome
there's one woman who's notorious or
who's famous for her virtue his name is
lucrecia and the prince thinks raping
her will
be the most fun okay because she will um
be the most insulted by this so he rapes
her and then she order she goes and
confronts her husband husband okay her
husband and her husband has a friend his
name is Lucius
Brutus Lucius Brutus happens to be the
nephew of the
king and he is very much opposed to the
tyranny of the king and lucua says to
her husband and to his friend Lucius
brutes I've been raped will you promise
me to avenge my honor and the husband
and Lucius Buddhas see she's distraught
okay and so they sue her and promise her
they will do uh everything they can in
the morning and
lucrecia um she she doesn't really
believe them so what she does is she
takes a knife out from her dress and she
stabs herself in the heart and she dies
before them now they are HonorBound to
avenge her death and so what Lucius
Buddhist does is he calls a meeting of
of the of the nobility and they decide
to gather to overthrow the king the king
is out
campaigning for war he he's basically at
War and what they do is they lock the
gates of Rome now the king is furious
okay and so what the king does
is he decides he's going to go back to
aishka where he's from and he's going to
Rally the other the his friends the
Kings okay because if the Romans can
overthrow him well other people can
overthrow their kings right so this is a
bad president so he's going to organize
a huge Army to March against Rome
meanwhile lucus brutas he's instituting
the Republic okay now the king the thing
of the king is that all powers are
invested in the king these powers
include
military
judicial um deciding cases uh
legislative making
laws uh administrative bureaucratic
right um and religious Okay so these are
the five major duties of the king and
this is where his power comes from so
what Lucius Buddhist and Romans do is
they separate his powers not into
individuals but into institutions that
are now elected by the people okay this
is the heart of republicanism so the
military will now run by the council the
council is basically the head of the
state okay and again he's elected the
the judicial is run by the pror
legislator is the
Senate uh administrative is the
adile and the religious is the pontifex
Maximus and again they all elected by
the people now what's important to
understand is it's usually nobility who
are on the or who are all who are in
these offices but back then there was
much separation between nobility and
Ordinary People Okay so are what we call
patricians the patricians and the
ordinary people are what we call the
plebians and honestly there was not that
much difference the patricians are just
come
from uh the longest like the families
who have been in Rome the longest the
oldest
families and they were wealthy but not
that much wealthier from orary Romans so
maybe you have one cow right well I have
three cows also
um the people could go visit each
other's homes without any ceremony okay
so you could be the head of state you
could be the councel but if I'm an
ordinary person I can just come to your
house and have dinner with you okay
there were no doors there were no guards
there's no
separation
okay so lucus BR Buddhas instituted a
new system where the king's Powers were
divided among different institutions
and now people didn't have to obey the
king they have to obey the Republic the
Republic had was three
things the laws the history or
traditions and the institutions
okay that's the Republic and this system
unbelievably incredibly will not change
for about 500 years okay so it's pretty
stable
now what's important to remember is
these are not Innovations the Romans
just basically copied this from the
neighbors okay the
atrians
right so the Romans have a republic the
problem with the Republic is everyone's
equal and so if you come from a
privileged background you find this very
annoying so now there's a conspiracy to
bring back the
king and and this conspiracy was
discovered and everyone was caught and
imprisoned it turns out lucus Buddhist
has two sons okay he has two sons and
they were both part of this
conspiracy they were Tried by the Senate
they were all sentenced to death
including two two sons of Lucius Buddhas
okay the problem is this the problem
is the council has to oversee the
execution
of the prisoners whose
Council lucus Buddhas is Council okay so
lucus Buddhas has to oversee the
execution of his two
sons now if Lucius Buddhist is like you
know what I'm going to resign my office
or hey you know what I'm I'm sick
everyone would be like we understand
take the day off don't worry about it
okay
instead lucus Buddhist
um showed up for work and he oversaw the
execution of his two sons all of Rome
came to the execution okay it was a
public
event everyone was watching the face of
Lucius Buddhist okay you we know the two
sons are going to die they're going to
get beheaded but everyone wanted to see
luc's Buddhist
reactions he was crying
throughout the execution these are his
two sons right
he has no more Sons this is his legacy
now and his two sons are are about to be
killed in fact he's he's the one charged
with killing his own Sons he has to do
it he has no choice so everyone's
watching him and throughout this process
he's crying his tears are flowing down
his face he can't help himself but he's
still standing still and he's still
slowly ordering the execution of his two
sons
and the Romans are just shocked
by this public
display okay this is the idea of
devotion right you are so devoted to
Rome that you're willing to sacrifice
your own children to ensure its survival
and its
Glory tar kinis uh talking the proud
hears about this he gets really angry so
he allies himself with Kings and they
marched against
Rome Lucius budus is Council he's in
charge of military so he marches his
Army against Tarkin the
proud one of the sons of Tarin the proud
sees lucus Brutus and he charges ahead
because he wants to kill the man who
insulted his
family lucus budha sees the King's son
running they they're both on horses
right running Galloping towards him and
lucif buddist gets angry and so he
charges ah head as well Lucius Buddhist
frows his spear Javelin the King's son
the prince froze his spear as well and
they spear each other to death and they
both die
okay and so Lucius Buddhist is at this
point
considered the greatest Roman whoever
lived okay and for most of Roman history
he will be considered the greatest Roman
whoever lived until Julius Caesar
okay and it was in the memory and honor
of Lucius Buddhist that they would
assassinate Julius Caesar but we we'll
discuss this next
class okay so um the king's Army is
overwhelming the Romans and the Romans
have to flee back into the
city there's a drawbridge that connects
Rome uh to the mainland okay so there's
the river Tyber crosses it crosses
around uh Rome there's a Garrison that's
supposed to be protecting the bridge but
they see the Army coming the enemy Army
marching towards them they get scared
and they run all
into
Rome one guy he's name his
cockos he decides I can't run away
because I run away the Army just marches
into Rome and kills everyone so he
descends he decides to make a Last Stand
and this it's just one guy there's one
random guy okay and what he does is he
starts shutting insults at the enemy
Army he's like you guys are slaves we're
Romans we will always be
free and the enemy Army and like there's
thousands of them okay they have
absolutely no idea what's going on this
is one guy on a bridge shining insulting
insulting them okay so they they
freeze eventually they realize oh this
guy is just distracting us because his
uh friends the other soldiers are trying
to cut down the bridge so they run to
him at this point two two other Romans
okay two officers run besides cockos and
together the three of them hold off the
invading Army together okay with their
Shields they fight for their
lives
eventually the bridge is about to be um
cut down okay the two officers run away
and caual makes the Last Stand
and the bridge Falls and what Kos does
is before it falls completely he jumps
into the Tyber and he survives he
doesn't
drown so this tells us hey
anyone can be a hero of Rome right
Lucius Buddhist he's the king's nephew
he's nobility but caual he's just an
ordinary Roman who had the courage he
had the Devotion to fight for Rome okay
and by doing so with his devotion he's
able to save Rome by
himself so Rome right now is surrounded
by this huge
Army and one young man his name is
musas and he's a Roman nobleman okay he
goes to the Senate and he says to the
Senate listen uh we're being surrounded
by an enemy Army the're huge we're
starving to death I have a plan to win
this war I'm going to swim across the
typer sneak into the enemy camp and kill
the enemy King and this war way the
Senate gives muus his approval and muus
sneaks into the enemy camp it's
payday which means the soldiers are
getting their wages right musia sneaks
into the front and he sees on the podium
there are two individuals who are giving
out wages to the soldiers
they both look like the king one's the
king and one's the secretary they look
the same muus doesn't know who's the
king and who's the secretary you know at
this point an orinary person would be
like I'll come back later okay like let
let me figure out let me spy first and
figure out who who the king is and then
when the better opportunity arises I'll
kill the king mushes is like it's 50/50
man so he takes his knife rushes to him
and stabs one of the man who happens to
be the secretary okay so he's arrested
and the king is now interrogating him he
wants to know there are other spies in
the camp and the King says to
muus tell me the truth or I will burn
you alive okay and he shows um musas the
P okay with this huge fire musas said
says I am one of a
100 young Romans who have pledged their
lives to kill you to free Rome okay he's
lying this is not
true you kill me there be 99 more okay
we are not afraid of you you say you
will burn me if I do not tell you the
truth now what he does is he puts his
hand Into the
Fire his hand is burning okay
and he holds it together and what makes
him hold it together is what he sees is
the face of luc's Buddhist as he orders
the execution of his two sons right
because ordering execution of your two
sons is a lot harder than burning your
hand alive okay than burning your
hand and the King he looks at this and
he thinks the Romans are the craziest
bastards
I have ever met screw this I'm going
home and he lets bu's go and the war is
over okay and that's how the Roman
Republic survived the invasion and
became the
Republic so this is the history
of Rome and this history
is something that can be taught to
anyone who becomes a citizen if you are
a Roman you you it's because you believe
in this history believing in this
history knowing this history is what
makes you a
Roman okay so that's the first
concept piety loyalty to Rome second
concept uh that makes you Rome uh unique
or powerful is the idea of
Liberty okay what Kos did what musas did
what Lucius Buddhist did was preserve
the liberty of Rome remember what
Liberty means
is respecting and following the laws
institutions and history of Rome because
that's what makes Rome Rome that's what
allows you to have
freedom okay and that's why in 2016 even
though Hannibal had defeated the Romans
the Romans refused to surrender because
surrendering would mean surrendering
their Liberty right because Hannibal
would impose peace terms that would that
would make basically Rome into a client
state of Carthage they would lose their
Liberty right and if you don't have
Liberty your life isn't worth
living give me life or Give me liberty
Okay the third element of Roman
greatness is the idea
of this right repu right so what this
means is every no
nobleman if you have the ability you
want to serve Rome okay so what they did
was this they turned wom politics into a
competition to to produce the best men
okay was basically
meritocracy so once you have the
financial means you stood for election
and this system was basically a
meritocracy okay you first stood for
election to become an edile and then you
became a pror and then you became a
councel once you're a councel you have
the opportunity to win the highest
Glory okay what you could do is become a
governor of a far away Province and if
you are governor of this part Province
and you can win more territory for Rome
then you'll be given something called a
Triumph
Triumph Triumph is a big parade where
you are celebrated by all the Roman
people that's what every
Roman soldier aspired to to become a
great General who would receive his own
Triumph because he's won New Territory
for Rome okay and that's why even though
a third of the Roman senate was wiped
out by
Hannibal they didn't give up because the
other people were like okay now here's
my opportunity to prove myself right and
one of these young people his name is
cpio he would go on and Lead an army
into Spain conquer Spain and then lead
an Army against Hannibal in North Africa
in Carthage and Destroy
Hannibal
okay because the point of life is to
receive the
Triumph and if you re receive the
Triumph then you then you will
remembered by Rome
in their history which is what gives
your life
meaning
okay all right so do we understand these
Concepts piety Liberty and Republica
because they are the essence of the
Roman identity and they are what made
Rome
great sure
okay all right so sorry Luci is Buddhist
okay Lucius Buddhist over the king they
established the Roman Republic Ro the
Roman Republic is now a nation of
laws his two sons are princes and they
lost their privileges so they partake in
this conspiracy to bring back the King
right this conspiracy was discovered and
as punishment they were all sentenced to
death because they wanted to destroy the
Republic and bring back the
king does that make
sense so uh what the what the story what
the and again we don't know if these
stories are true they're probably not
true okay what the story is telling us
is if the founder of the Roman Republic
can sacrifice his family in order to
make sure Republic survives well you can
as well okay no sacrifice
um every sacrifice must be made to
ensure Roman greatness that's basically
the
message right any more
questions that's a great question okay
so how do we know this the answer is
this for most of this time this is what
we call oral
history okay so this is like you know
mythology and it
was basically passed from generation to
Generation Um this oral history was
written down in books but because Rome
was at War so much um Rome was conquered
once and um Rome was burnt down and so
we lost a lot of the written history
okay now the problem with oral history
is there are different versions of oral
history okay so there are different
versions of these
stories and then um a man name Nam Livy
uh during the time of uh the Roman
Empire when it was first
founded he sat down to WR the official
History of Rome and this is where we get
all these stories from okay and again uh
we don't believe these stories to be
that true okay there's probably there's
Lucius bu probably a real person but he
whether not he did these things we don't
know okay it's
debatable um but what matters is this is
what Romans belied okay do you
understand what matters is what they
believe as opposed to what really
happened and this is what uh creates the
Roman
identity
right great any more
questions
okay
so yeah I mean that's basically it okay
this is what made Rome great and that's
what allowed them to come back from the
defeats that Hannibal inflicted on them
to eventually win the
war
okay any more any more questions
80,000 Army against Hannibal
yes okay that that's a great question
okay so like you want you want to know
more about hanbal invasion of Italy
right okay all right so
Rome what Rome is able to do is offer
citizenship to anyone who fights for
Rome and Rome is has been for the
longest time been fighting its neighbors
right once it conquer its neighbors its
neighbors promised to send soldiers to
Rome in times of War so Rome is able to
draw on soldiers from all around the
Italian
Peninsula okay that's the first thing
second thing is is that when Hannibal
invaded
Italy he was doing so with many Gs okay
who are the Invaders of Italy and these
GS have traditionally been the enemy of
the
Italians so when hanal did so uh Rome's
neighbors rallied to Rome's support to
support Rome okay because they saw the
goals and Hannibal as Invaders who
threaten um their culture okay the
second thing the third thing
is Hannibal had an invading Army right
but he had no organizational and
logistic
support he had no food supply because he
was basically doing this on his own
initiative Carthage is too far away okay
and Rome had the best like Navy in the
Mediterranean so there was no way that
Carthage could we Supply
um Hannibal sorry there's no way
Carthage could resupply Hannibal
right so Hannibal was forced to spend a
lot of his time forging for
food do you understand and that's why
ultimately why he lost the war because
it's possible for you to win all these
battles because you're a military genius
but you still have to feed your
soldiers and what Rome did after the
battle of Canaan was they recognized
this fact they recognized
that uh Hannibal's m problem was
Logistics and they started to not they
they would they decided we will never
fight Hannibal in a battle again we will
cut off his food supply okay and so
Hannibal had to spend most of his time
forging for
food meanwhile Rome could rebuild Itself
by freeing its slaves okay and by um uh
recruiting more neighbors to to join
their cause okay does that make
sense okay that's why
that's
why armies don't win Wars Nations win
Wars does that make sense so another
thing that you you need to understand is
while Hannibal was winning
glory in Italy the C of Elders in car
were they happy about this do you
think these are business people right
are they happy about this they're not
happy about this because one it's it's
going to cost a lot of money to to
continue the war and
listen Italy is poor so there's no
profit to be made from conquering Rome
okay that's the first problem second
problem is if Hannibal were to win glory
in Italy he put come back and make it's
some king of Carthage right does that
make sense so Hannibal was being
undermined by Carthage itself even
though Hannibal was trying to save
Carthage does that make
sense and that's what makes Rome
unique Rome has been United for most of
its history whereas most places like
gree and carage were divided into
different political factions that's what
caused um carage to ultimately uh be
undermined so ultimately Rome was able
to come back from the AED and defeat
Carthage because Carthage again saw
Hannibal uh as big as a a threat as Rome
okay this would this would be costly for
Carthage because after the war is over
50 years
later uh Rome a Roman Senator named K
the Elder he vs it Carthage because he's
curious what's happened to Carthage
after the end of the war and to his
dismay and to his shock
Carthage has become wealthier than ever
before okay
50 years of Peace means that carage is
able to accumulate more wealth than ever
before it has so much wealth that that
is able to pay
off the indemnity that Rome imposed on
it okay it's basically able to pay off
pay Rome off and K kid the
Elder he
is uh traumatized by this he goes back
to Roman and says we have to destroy
Carthage okay there's a huge debate in
the Senate he says listen if we let
carage survive carage will always be a
threat to us and the other senators were
like listen KO I know you want to
destroy Carthage but remember Carthage
threatens us if we destroy
Carthage we Rome will no longer have an
enemy we will no longer have a
threat we will change as a people if we
destroy Carthage
but C the Elder insisted eventually an
army was dispatched to um destroy
Carthage the Romans have a habit
of always blaming the enemies for
starting the war okay so they didn't
want to instigate the war so they made
these dumb excuses and said that carfit
was violating the peace treaty and the
Roman said to carfit listen if you
surrender all your weapons we will go
away the carthaginian
believed the Romans and thought if they
surrender all the
weapons they go away the Romans got all
these weapons they were like we didn't
expect this man so the Roman said to the
carthaginians you know what um we also
need you to move your City from the
coast 10 kilometers in land okay and at
this point the caragan knew Rome was
going to destroy Carthage so there's a
three-year Siege and and and then at the
end of it Rome conquered Carthage killed
everyone inside enslaved others burned
all the books and wiped out carage from
history as well as the history books
okay so that's a Roman
mentality devotion means All or Nothing
okay you don't surrender but you also
don't show Mercy to your
enemies okay so Hannibal was right Rome
was a threat to Carthage
but because Carthage has a merchant
culture run by business people they
could never recognize the
threat does that make sense all
right any more
questions
good public virtue yeah
okay so why do people when to come to
Rome well the fact of matter is that for
most of history for most of history
people didn't want to go to Rome because
Rome was considered a um like for
example the Greeks didn't want to go to
Rome because they thought Rome was
uncivilized and and Roman but Romans
wanted to go to Athens because they
thought Athens was a height of
civilization right the car carthaginians
certainly didn't want to go go to Rome
okay Rome was like Macedonia it's
basically North Korea even you can even
say it's like North Korea okay it's a
militaristic society that's barbaric
right the Greeks like to watch theater
the Romans like to watch Gladiator shows
or lions eat people okay so for most of
its history people avoided Rome when it
became a republic you had no choice but
to go to Rome because that's how you
could build your career it it was the
capital of the
world
okay does that make sense so I know
we're saying this is there were many
people who want to be Greek because they
were attracted by the culture nobody
wanted to be Roman the Romans made
everyone into a Roman through the
conquest so uh the Romans were uh
repugnant in many ways okay they just
they just were a repugnant
people okay any more
questions any more any more questions
okay great so next class we it's a fun
class we do Julius Caesar okay